in the second season of discovery
pike gets this glimpse into the future
um obviously that's going to be kind of
a shocking thing do we see some of that
come through into strange new worlds and
where is he kind of mentally when we
reunite with him
yeah we knew very early on that
we uh we couldn't really do the show
without
dealing with that question at the top
there was no room to deal with it in
this 13th and 14th episodes of season
two of star trek discovery
uh for
very clear
uh situational plot reasons
uh but we had to deal with it here
and
rather we also knew that rather than
sort of mention it and sidestep it or
deal with it quickly and move on we just
we decided and or i should say kevin
henry decided very wisely to jump into
it and
attack it in a way that that
feeds into the development of the
character
and the show itself
uh and i'm i'm very pleased
with how they did that right through
the entire entire season one uh we have
a mutual friend and dan who directed i
believe it's episode four of season one
oh yeah he's easier right now oh that's
excellent he's doing episode six of
season two now excellent i also know
somebody another person who directed for
season two but what has it been like
getting to
interact with different directors for
this and getting different approaches to
star trek through them it's been amazing
uh on this show more than any other
because
we're actually encouraging our directors
to come in
because we're episodic and we want each
episode to be its own thing we've been
encouraging the directors to come in
with their own visions not only in terms
of lenses or style but
which genre do you want to do
what um
what do you want to see what do you want
to see on the enterprise that you've
never seen before what episode are you
most excited for fans to see in season
one
oh man
i know it's a hard question
that is so hard well i'm very excited
about season four actually dan dan
dan knocked it out of the park
and it it was not just me seeing that
saying that i mean other directors were
mentioning his episode
uh and how good it is uh and it was not
an easy episode right
for reasons that i can't spoil right
it was a tough episode
and did he do well with it
um yes that's why we have him back
i've got to ask in the premiere you get
to ride a horse what is the horse's name
and did you feel like you were reliving
hell on meals
[Laughter]
no because the horse's name was pretty
oh my gosh
well you know i had asked for you know
pike's
pikes horse that that we were introduced
to in the original pilot was
was a
was a a fawn
we couldn't find it they didn't have a
fawn available so we got a black horse
but she was great
you just got to be really careful when
you're working in the snow with horses
because they get tired out really quick
and she was uh
she was super sturdy and and obedient
and
like to look at herself in the mirror
uh we have these mirrors in the
equestrian center where we were working
and she would constantly get distracted
with her own her own image i guess
that's why they call it pretty oh i love
that uh and then for a final fun
question if you could switch roles with
any other character in strange new
worlds who would it be and why
oh boy
um
it wouldn't be strange new worlds it
would be it would be the next generation
i
made no secret of this and i've told
them before
data is i think
one of the most maybe the most
imaginative interesting characters in
star trek canon
he's pinocchio in space
such a
such an actor's dream
to play
a non-sentient
being that has to learn what sentience
is it's uh
i was so jealous as a young watching him
get to do that oh that's excellent well
thank you so much
thank you